la policía empujó a los periodistas y
trató de bloquear las cámaras para que
no grabaran esto a medida que la tensión
aumentaba a las afueras de la corte de
shanghai dentro la periodista ciudadana
yangcheng fue sentenciada a cuatro años
de prisión meses después de publicar
vídeos y ensayos de buján en los
primeros días de la pandemia fue acusada
por buscar pelea y causar problemas sus
abogados dicen que sólo trataba de
compartir información
en otros países hay libertad de
expresión y de prensa pero en china no
es igual y alguien quiso ayudar a la
gente de wuhan ella quiso entender su
sufrimiento y dejar que el mundo
exterior supiera que podían evitar este
tipo de crisis incluso mejor
los reportes de jiang tuvieron mucho
impacto en redes sociales en febrero y
fueron a veces críticos con la respuesta
del gobierno abogada de formación
jiang se declaró en huelga de hambre
y fue forzada a alimentarse con una
sonda nasal es también una de las
detenidas por las autoridades por
ofrecer testimonio de primera mano sobre
jan el compañero periodista change you
see ha desaparecido por completo los
medios estatales han aplaudido la
gestión de la pandemia del gobierno
dando crédito al presidente jinping por
mantener al país a salvo